this is not okay i think you'll be good
we've made it this far what's that i
know what this is what is it yeah what
do you got going on
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by jessica alba
she's an actress whose career in
hollywood checks everything from box
office blockbusters to cult classics
she's also a tremendously successful
businesswoman as founder of the honest
company
and you can catch her starring in la's
finest mondays at 8 7 central on fox
jessica alba welcome to the show thanks
for having
me so i understand that you take hot
sauces to set
how are you though going into this with
spicy food
i'm nervous but let's see because like i
feel like i can i feel like i can handle
some heat
classic blue label
okay
i like that you eat this with us i feel
like it's important that i do that to
meet you halfway because like
if you're dying on hot sauce and i'm
just sitting here like some jerk barking
questions at you would you just keep
going on and on and on maybe not
what the hell why did i take such a big
bite
[Music]
so as we mentioned up top you start
alongside gabrielle union in la's finest
the tv
offshoot of the bad boys franchise and
also a show that you guys are both eps
on i'm curious
when you're acting and producing at the
same time
does that affect the mental math in your
head when you think about the balance
between art and commerce
what's great about commerce is it gives
you boundaries to work within
and i feel like the best art is
within some type of boundary
um when you're sort of like confined to
you only have this much budget right and
you have to hit
these sort of notes it's like a song
every act
has to hit a pitch so that people want
to tune back in and not
click over to somewhere else i i
actually appreciate
the balance and i feel like when you do
have commerce
uh and art combined um
it sort of gives you also a reason
because a lot of art is just subjective
and who knows if it's good
[Music]
good i feel like i'm into that
now i know when my kids get in trouble
instead of making them do push-ups
i can say you guys can eat some hot
sauce
yeah that doesn't surprise me i've heard
that from people like if you say a swear
word they'll hit you with some hot sauce
or something
stop fighting or else your mom's gonna
make you eat some hot sauce
so i want to take a wing to talk about
honey the 2013
film has cult status for being like a
time capsule for early 2000's hip-hop
culture
in that film you know you have to learn
ballet you have to learn jazz you have
to learn hip-hop and all in kind of like
this short three-month crash course
having had that unique experience what
is the style of dance that's hardest to
master
i would say ballet and jazz
because there's very specific beats and
i could never get the spinning down i
think i got
whiplash too much when i was doing
stunts on dark angel
so every time i spin i was like
where i would like get vertigo like i
was messed up and like the best dancers
can do like a
spin like a proper spin not me
that's when i was like stun double help
me with this one
hennessy was like a performance enhancer
on set is that true um
what was the drink everyone used to
drink back in the day
hypnotic hypnosis do you remember that
i was not that error or is that before
was that before your time
i just missed it i just missed it i just
missed it
but sometimes i didn't know how to get
out of my head and and certainly even
especially when i was doing something i
wasn't good at like dancing
and i was surrounded by like
professional dancers and choreographers
and
real music artists and i just um
yeah maybe i maybe i took a shot or two
before a few scenes
shaquanda west indian curry
shout out shaqwanda friend of the
program
mm-hmm into it you dig that one
[Music]
so someone who scaled the heights of the
movie making business then also launched
their own extremely successful consumer
goods startup with the honest company i
think you're uniquely qualified to weigh
in on this
where do you find harsher critics on
movie review sites
or on health and beauty blogs definitely
movie reviews
i feel like a lot of movie reviewers
and maybe i'm speaking out of turn
especially
now but even then they love a good
headline it's all about the headline
and it's all about like a salacious
headline
and for some reason scandal seems to
prevail over you complimenting someone
i for whatever reason have been on the
other side of the burn
every time i don't actually think i've
ever had a good review in my entire
career
but i'm cool with it i'm hearing hot
ones
[Music]
it's like a chipotle something oh
i'm scared yeah it's got uh
it's got definitely like a richer
deeper pepper vibe on this one mm-hmm
mm-hmm it's smoky
what did you take nice with like a
mescal like
mixed margarita type drink i love when
guests give good pairings i love that
you're you're kind of a foodie you know
a little bit i think like like amateur
foodie like me maybe
listen i like to go to restaurants i can
order off a menu
in an amazing way you've never seen
anyone order off a menu quite like me
i'm telling you that
when are we going to dinner whenever you
want whenever you want jessica alba i
jump at the opportunity
but you when it comes to you know like
you're a little more multifaceted
because you're in the kitchen quite a
bit i spend no time in the kitchen
yeah but i can order this [ __ ] out of
dinner
respect respect yeah i
like try all the things and i make sure
that everything is covered my bases are
covered
that's exactly same thing i'm like all
right let's take two of these appetizers
let's take two of these sides
let's try one out of this column let's
try an entree out of that column i make
sure that i'm covering all the bases
because i feel like most people are just
simple and one track minded and they
just want their like
you know mac and cheese and burger but i
appreciate someone who is willing to
to try it all hey right here with you on
there
[Music]
okay you're just like getting a big old
bite this is really good
this is nice all right jessica we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story here's
a nice throwback what do you remember
about
spending the day golfing with john daly
one of the best days of my life he is a
[ __ ] legend preach oh my god
he is a fun and his his wife
uh was there as well this is caddy
um he's just
solid man he like sneezes
and the ball goes 350 yards straight
down the line you're like what he was
really nice with me but i
but you know i can see how he can you
know be tough on people especially in
his
heyday and he like talked about all the
things
and was like an open book and and was
just really cool and
gave me pointers on how to better my
swing and he's
he's dope he's a good time have you been
bombing him off the tee with like an
extra 20 30 yards ever since that day
when i was around him i like i like got
some of his
like daily energy and i felt like i had
definitely a more
solid swing and maybe i i didn't chip
the ground
prior to hitting the ball as much as i
would have
before but yeah it's uh he's he's really
cool
and then spacex is dope did you visit
the uh headquarters in hawthorne what
prompted this
i did a friend of mine who was my agent
is friends with elon and he was like do
you want to go
to spacex and then also elon's chief of
staff
knew my business partner and i was like
of course i do
like who yes and i just wanted to see
the whole
operation just see like the supply chain
and how
it works and it's the hub for a lot of
their innovation
and i just thought it was so cool and i
you know got to see a rocket
and and the bolts and
and learn why you know they can get up
in the air
so quickly and differently than others
and it was just like
really really cool and i also am like
one of those nerds because i've had so
many different offices
over the years with honest i always like
to suss out like
what's their food layout you know like
how do they do
offices is it an open floor plan like
where did the executives sit you know
compared to where everyone else and
i just love to look at that stuff and
nerd out so
yeah i i i loved it and then finally
do you have a snoop dogg party story
that you can share with us
so many i've known snoop for a long time
oh snoop um there's one i will never
tell
publicly because i'm not sure if what we
did
was totally legal well this isn't public
this is just like
two people talking over the zoo
but prior to
we being legal maybe
snoop offered me a blunt maybe
a few times that we were in miami
or l.a or new york
[Music]
oh god
there's no there's not a lot of profiles
it's just
it's just spicy right that that diesel
that diesel
hit got you in the throat
a little bit you know it's not easy on
this end always you know what i'm saying
jessica to try to try to
keep keep the interview going do all
that you know i think sometimes
i think sometimes the audience can kind
of like take for granted that i'm just
over your housing wings you know what i
mean like sometimes i don't even think
they notice
i notice i noticed well thank you
jessica it means a lot to me
i i think about it every time i really
do
so your breakthrough role came from an
early 2000s sci-fi series called dark
angel which was actually james cameron's
tv debut
and then the thing about that show is it
had this massive 12 million dollar
budget for the pilot
and then it had this dystopian sort of
vibe that i think was very much ahead of
its time
i just have so much respect for someone
like jim that
rallies hundreds of people every day on
a set
around his vision and gets gets it done
he really is one of my mentors still
very much an
inspiration for me you know he when
there weren't cameras that could do
the effects that he wanted he then went
and built them
and created them you're like what when
cameras didn't go to
depths of the ocean where he wanted to
film he went and built a submarine
you're like what is happening like who
does this
him he does this and i just love his
curiosity still
and he really wants to make an impact
i i uh yeah can't say enough
great things about the guy
[Music]
so it's like a bourbon i'm already
sweating so
you're doing very good though you're
doing very good
oh my god i'm with you
i'm right with you son of 2005 marie
claire profile
you just don't drink you don't drink
anything you know i typically kind of
mirror the guest
uh oh god you don't have milk
but i know this is honey milk honey milk
with ice
you guys made it or it's honey and milk
i know i put honey
this much honey and my oat milk with ice
because i read
that that helps with the heat but it's
not really doing that in sugar
that's what i always say you know people
yell at me for having water over here on
the desk all the time and i'm like
listen
psychologically it helps me out a little
bit all right like leave me alone about
this whole thing
like once you eat these wings it's not
like oh i take a sip of milk and i'm
fine all of a sudden like you're
there's no saving you you know no that's
why i have these
they're called antacids and i have the
right
guy actually i'm gonna take one so
prepared i feel like
i just feel like my gut is gonna wake me
up at two in the morning
on fire and i just then i get heart
palpitations it's like it's a whole
thing
well speaking of frightening experience
i'm curious
what's the most harrowing experience you
had shooting
face to face with actual live sharks and
into the blue
you know for some reason they caught a
wild tiger shark
um i don't know they had it in a cage or
something in the back of a boat
and they were like it's in this cage so
it's docile
it's not and i'm like it's a [ __ ]
tire shark and it was like a
seven foot tiger shark and they're like
in the scene we just want it to like
go by you guys and they're like all
right get in
because you know in this scene the shark
has to come really close to you and i
was like
i mean you guys can do this with a a
double or b second unit and i
i was on flipper we had [ __ ] rubber
dolphins
you can do this with a goddamn rubber
doll but you don't need a real ass shark
in the middle of the [ __ ] ocean with
chum
um and maybe i lost my mind and maybe i
yelled all of that
and the director was like you know what
come on just get in the water it'll be
three seconds
it's fine come on we don't have time
we're losing the light dude
all the things and i said [ __ ] you [ __ ]
your face and you get in the water
and then i got on a boat and
went back to shore so yeah
not my best decisions were made on that
movie
well you know what you live to fight on
another day
and here we are living to fight on
another sauce
and i have to warn you going into this
one this is the bomb beyond insanity
yeah this is the one where everyone goes
like hard
hard left or hard right
she's she's seen the show before yes i
have
yes i have
and that looks doused like that looks
heavy
oh [ __ ] oh god yep
[Music]
what if i have allergic reaction
this is not okay i think it'll be good
we've made it this far what's i don't
know what this is what is it yeah what
do you got going on
that's not good why did i do that what
is this sour cream
it's sour cream
what the [ __ ] is that it's a it's a very
disgusting hot sauce that's stupid
i'm with you 100 on that one i'll take
this up
how does it get any better how does it
get any better
the the good news is we're approaching
the finish line here just a couple more
hurdles to jump through
is that more sour cream
this next question has a nice long wind
up for you okay
just survive it just survive it not okay
so jessica you're a celebrity judge on
planet of the apps which was a shark
tank like competition series for tech
empresarios
so what i want to do here is hit you
with a handful of apps
some of them are in the app store some
of them we totally made up
and i just want to see if you can tell
the real from the fake
and i'm curious whether or not you think
it's a good idea or not hang on a minute
[Music]
i just um just got the back of my throat
you know
yeah no i feel you i'm like drooling i
understand how that can go it kind of
it takes over your body at this point
you know
but it's just taking over my [ __ ]
throat no yeah it hasn't gotten to my
body yet
got that got that i got a little uh i'm
flushed in the face a little bit
i feel you i understand i understand
we'll work through this one together
all right first you know how people get
like a little bit hallucinating
sometimes like on this show like i'll
walk out of the studio like on a high a
little bit
[Music]
first app alright alright alright a
meditation app that plays a loop of
matthew mcconaughey reciting texas
witticisms over
soft guitar music it's a terrible idea
but i wouldn't be surprised if it exists
spooner a social meetup app where users
living within walking distance of each
other
can link up for casual strictly platonic
cuddling i think that might actually
exist
it does exist i think i need ice
ice someone get her some ice
that's wrong like nothing does nothing
help
uh we're in it we're just kind of in it
together
what about that what's that peanut
butter
how's that working out i don't know
just i i'd i'd love for you to report
back the findings afterwards you know
you mean what happens to my [ __ ]
bowels after this
no no no that that you can keep to
yourself i'm curious i'm curious uh
what finding i'm finding if any of these
antidotes actually work
you know something that we can have on
set ready to go
in in case of these situations this is
feeling better
okay good peanut butter we'll put that
in the wind column
all right i want on my lips nacho hunter
a dating app that uses a personality
algorithm to pair you with someone who
likes the same nachos as you do
i wish that existed because i would
subscribe to that one
that's all i care about our nachos could
be our next big idea it could be our
next big idea because it is fake all
right
last one drunk mode an app that locks
certain contacts in your phone for a
preset amount of time when you're
partying in an effort to keep you from
drunk dialing or drunk texting
yeah yeah i mean that's [ __ ] genius
how many times have you drunk
dialed they should do that for like
drunk
drunk posting on social media there you
go
protect us from ourselves kind of ironic
given the uh circumstances right now
where we are just eating some of the
spiciest chicken wings ever
i'm getting have you ever seen one of
these what is that a tongue depressor
it's a ball that you put in the freezer
and you roll your face to make it look
not as puffy
but it's going to be on standby for this
next one think of it fascinating
yeah let me put some more um
lip gloss barrier i have so much respect
for you
you do yeah i mean do you ever do your
blood pressure while you're doing this
but you're still young thank you thank
you i don't know but i
this this might be taking some years off
but i am always curious about that like
if they just like
hooked me up and you could like kind of
see all the vitals and stuff while it's
going on because there is a lot cooking
yeah there is god damn
be very careful this one
it's made by a guy named smokin ed curry
who we've worked with
he grows extremely hot peppers he made
this one
and it has that deep peppery
make you sweat from your face smoke and
egg flavor profile that he's famous for
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to breathe a little bit what's
uh what's that
that seems new honey oh some honey
[Music]
fascinating your early guest star cameos
they run the gamut but i am curious
about two in particular
which was a more positive on-set
experience for you
playing alex max rival jessica in the
secret life of alex mack
or playing a pregnant teenager in 90210
yeah i know i i didn't really i got
bullied as a kid
so it was sort of wish fulfillment
maybe to be able to play someone that
was bullying me
essentially um
and uh on the set of 90210 i couldn't
even make eye contact
with any of the cast members which was
really strange
when you're like trying to do a scene
with them
yeah i was like you're not allowed to
make eye contact with any one of the
cast members or you'll be thrown off
throughout the set
[Music]
this is the thick-ass sauce cheers
jessica what a ride it's been
[Music]
we're flying we're flying it's all over
it's all
over almost all over because you know
what jessica alba here we are at the
conclusion
of our spicy wing flight we've talked
about
your career in acting your many power
moves as a business woman but i want to
end on talking about your world view
on joseph gordon-levitt's podcast i
heard you discussing wabi-sabi a concept
from japanese aesthetics that embraces
imperfections
what do you see is the artistic appeal
of having a constant reminder
that nothing is forever and nothing is
perfect
[Music]
what i love about wabi-sabi
it's very the appeal
of wabi-sabi and how i i think why i'm
attracted to it so much and this
japanese philosophy around embracing
imperfections
at the end of the day if you can feel a
connection to
memories and stories and things that
surround you
there's nothing more beautiful and it
reminds you
to live your life to the fullest and
all of those nicks and cran crannies and
and all the imperfections and the bro
even the breaks and the vases or
in the wall or in things with and you
mend it a little bit here and there
it just tells you that that life is good
man
and it was lived to the fullest this is
what this is what helped
let me take some notes you need a good
lip balm lip balm coating
you need oat milk with a lot of [ __ ]
honey
a generous squeeze of honey okay milk
yeah and like mix it up
you know get it in there with ice you
definitely
need vanilla yogurt vanilla yogurt god
damn it it got
all of those those hauls in the back of
my throat
where are my tonsils definitely peanut
butter
and these balls peanut butter
and the balls thank you so much
jessica alba for giving me that crash
course
now please let me return the favor by
rolling out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera or possibly a
camera b
or c or whatever you have set up at that
a great setup over there
let the people know what you have going
on in your life um
i have the honest company we make
uh it really is a company that is built
around social impact i wanted to make a
difference in the world and if we can do
it
and make money and help people and help
the planet
let's do that we make everything from
cleaning products to baby products to
beauty products
and then la's finest lots of
action fun kick-ass um
and juicy stories and gabrielle union
and i
just like cracking jokes and having a
good time in that bad boy universe
so check it out
good job jessica good job good job and
we need to have dinner next time you're
in l.a
innovating it's just so hot
who am i
whoa mixing anything i'll do anything
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's video
and join me in welcoming the newest
member
of the hot ones hot sauce family this is
the last dab apollo
the only sauce made with the apollo
pepper
the latest and greatest from the twisted
mind of smoking ed curry
it is the hottest last ab we've ever
made and the people who will taste it
first
are the subscription box subscribers who
will get this one
in october's box for everyone else
probably sometime later in october
heatness.comheatness.com to learn more
about the last dab apollo moment of
silence
for the last dab triple x but it's okay
all new beginnings
must come from some other beginning's
end